Imagine a line of people all waiting to
get their hands on the best chocolate
pancakes in existence.
The way this works is the person
who's been in the line the longest
gets her pancakes and gets out first.
People can join on this end, but
only people on this end get
their pancakes and leave.
You could perhaps call this a first in,
first out structure or a queue.
A queue is kind of the opposite
of a stack in this way.
In a stack the most recently added
element comes out first, but
here the oldest element comes out first.
Otherwise queues are actually
pretty similar to stacks.
The first element in a queue, or
the oldest element in the queue,
is called the head.
The last element in the queue, or
the newest element in the queue,
is called the tail.
When you add an element to the tail,
the operation is called enqueue.
When you remove the head element,
the operation is called dequeue.
There's also an operation called peek,
where you look at the head element but
you don't actually remove it.
Again, you can implement this data
structure with a linked list,
where you also save
references to the head and
tail so you can look them
both up in constant time.
There are actually two special
types of queues that show up a lot.
A dequeue or double-ended queue
is a queue that goes both ways.
You can enqueue or
dequeue from either end.
If you think about it,
a deck is kind of a generalized
version of both stacks and queues.
Since you could represent either of them
with it, you could treat it like a stack
and add and remove elements from
the same end, or you could treat it like
a queue and add elements on one end and
remove them from the other.
Let's examine a priority queue now.
In a priority queue you
assign each element
a numerical priority when you
insert it into the queue.
When you dequeue, you remove
the element with the highest priority.
This doesn't really follow
the rules of a normal queue,
where you remove
the oldest element first.
However, if the elements
have the same priority
the oldest element is the one
that gets dequeued first.